[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, Lorraine Cink here
for the Women of Marvel.
And I am going to be talking
with the incredible Mary
Livanos from Marvel
Studios, the director
of production and development.
Yes.
Hello.
What does a director of
production and development
do at Marvel Studios?
Sure.
Because I've realized, you
know, a lot of our friends
that are listening to this
are going to say, that's cool.
What is that?
It changes with every film.
But for Captain
Marvel it was my job
to help make sure that
creatives, across the board
in every department,
had all the tools
and resources that they needed
in order to tell the story.
So let's talk a little
bit about Captain Marvel.
Yeah.
Now, you talked about
supporting the other, sort of--
- All the different departments.
Yes.
Providing key art from the
great Kelly Sue DeConnick
runs and the early Captain
Marvel runs, to working very
closely with the Air Force.
You guys worked
with two different Air
Force bases, correct?
- Yes.
Yes.
The film shot at
Edwards Air Force Base,
but the bulk of our research
we conducted at Nellis Air
Force Base with the 57th Wing.
Speaking with every
pilot that we could,
getting inside their
heads, and they
offered to fly Brie and Anna
Boden up in fighter jets.
And I said, haha,
you're kidding.
And they were not.
That was wild.
So when you go back
and watch the film now--
you've probably seen it a
lot more than most of us--
what part, like, makes you feel
the most proud do you think?
There are a lot of parts
that made me very proud.
I'll take them all.
The message that Carol
Danvers didn't need fixing.
Mm-hmm.
That's what gives me chills
when I think about the movie.
Yeah, the thing that always,
kind of, stuck with me is
there's very much
a feeling of, like,
you are enough the way you are.
And that realization
that she sort of has.
In a movie, a
character has problem,
then, by the end of the movie,
you need to fix that problem.
Carol, it was the unexpected
discovery of that didn't
necessarily need to happen.
And it was about self discovery.
Moments that make me
really, really happy,
when Carol screams
back at the skrull.
Yeah.
That feels so Carol.
I love Goose.
I love Goose so much.
Oh, and I love that
Nick Fury is a cat man.
I just--
[BOTH LAUGHING]
It's just, like, a great fun
detail for the Marvel universe.
- Who would have thunk?
- Yeah.
Mary, thank you so much
for talking with us today.
Thank you so
much for having me.
Go pick up Marvel Studios'
Captain Marvel, now on digital
and on Blu-ray on June 11th.
[MUSIC PLAYING]